time now for the uplifted eight stories
that will bring some joy to your day
vlad's here with a dose of Joy what do
you got black be the best thing you see
all day one little girl is proving you
don't have to be big to be strong take a
look at her amazing accomplishment
during a carnival game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is nine-year-old Raleigh Webb who
held on to that bar longer than anyone
else including an adult at the
California State Fair in Sacramento she
held on for 90 seconds Raleigh surprised
everyone with her strength including her
parents
see her do something so amazing
something that you know not many people
can do something that is you know
impossible to some I felt so proud job
probably told us it felt good to show
people that she could win that's right
home with the awesome prize of a stuffed
donut I was just about donut stuff donut
the best part Riley was her mom I know I
love the fact that her mom was cheering
her on so hard I just hold on hold on
baby hold on oh that meant a lot to her
that was very nice very nice Vlad